tenemos la ecuación am 12 elevado a la
menos 2 x 1 entre 72 todo esto elevado a
la quinta potencia igual a 2 elevado a
la x 3 elevado a la b y bueno lo que
queremos hacer es que esta ecuación se
cumpla para un valor de amd y para un
valor de b y para esto lo que vamos a
hacer es tratar de utilizar todo lo que
hemos aprendido acerca de las leyes los
exponentes para llegar a una relación
entre esta expresión de aquí y esta
expresión de acá y bueno lo primero que
se me ocurre es que la parte de la
izquierda de esta ecuación esté 12 y
este 72 vamos a intentar expresar lo en
potencias que tengan que ver con 2 y con
3 para que así tengamos las mismas bases
tanto la base 2 como la base 3 y podamos
igualar sus potencias por ejemplo aquí
tengo el 12 y el 12 lo podemos ver como
3 por 4 como 3
por cuatro y bueno el 2 está elevado a
la potencia menos 2 así que esto a su
vez está elevado a la potencia menos 2 y
date cuenta que aquí el 3 bueno
claramente ya es una potencia de 3
mientras que el 4 claramente también ya
es una potencia de 2 porque el 4 es
exactamente lo mismo que 2 elevado al
cuadrado y bueno de hecho justo ahorita
voy a escribir al 4 como 2 al cuadrado
pero bueno antes quiero fijarme también
en 1 372 y darse cuenta que esta parte
de adentro 1 entre 72 lo podemos
escribir de la siguiente manera esto es
lo mismo que uno entre y 72 lo voy a ver
como 8 por 9 8 por 9 y bueno todo esto
todo esto está elevado a la quinta
potencia a esto lo voy a multiplicar por
esto elevado a la quinta potencia y
ahora quiero que te des cuenta algo muy
padre 8 tiene que ver con una potencia
de 2 dichos 2 al cubo y 9 también tiene
que ver con una potencia de 3 de hecho
es 3 al cuadrado justo eso no voy a
utilizar en un ratito y esto tiene que
ser igual a 2 ala por 3 árabe y para no
estar copiando esto siempre solamente
voy a trabajar con la parte izquierda y
ya que tenga todo relacionado con
potencias de 2 y con potencias de 3
entonces va a ser el momento ideal de
traer esta parte de aquí e igualdad los
exponentes pero ahorita vamos a trabajar
solamente con la parte izquierda
ahora hay una propiedad de los
exponentes que nos dice que dos números
multiplicándose elevados a una potencia
es exactamente lo mismo que la
multiplicación de cada uno de estos
números elevados a esa misma potencia es
decir que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 3 elevado a la potencia menos 2 a la
potencia menos 2 por a por cuatro por
cuatro elevado a la potencia menos 2
elevado a la potencia menos 2 y bueno
justo ahorita voy a escribir a este 4 a
este de aquí como 2 elevado al cuadrado
y ahora fíjate que esta expresión de
aquí esta expresión de aquí y déjame
tomar otro color esto que tenemos aquí
adentro es exactamente lo mismo que
escribirlo de la siguiente manera por am
y voy a abrir un paréntesis y en lugar
de poner 1 entre 8 por 9 lo voy a
escribir como un 1 entre 81 octavo por
un noveno y al final por una
multiplicación de fracciones estas dos
expresiones son equivalentes
y todo esto elevado a la quinta potencia
y bueno lo padre es que el 4 ya lo
podemos ver como una potencia del 2
entonces justo ahora te lo voy a
escribir como a aquí tengo 3 elevado a
la menos 2 a la menos 2 y el 4 es
exactamente lo mismo que 2 elevado al
cuadrado entonces esto por a 2 elevado
al cuadrado y esto a su vez está elevado
a la potencia menos 2 2 elevado al
cuadrado es 4 y 4 ésta a su vez elevado
la potencia menos 2 ok esto por esta
primera parte y ahora vamos a fijarnos
en esta parte de aquí porque quiero que
te des cuenta que éste un octavo y
déjame cambiar de color para que lo veas
mejor
un octavo lo puedo ver y vamos
escribirlo aquí un octavo lo podemos ver
como a 1 entre 2 elevado al cubo o lo
que es lo mismo a 2 elevado a la menos 3
recuerda que cuando tengo una potencia
negativa puedo pasar esta expresión con
una potencia positiva si ella tomó con
un denominador de una fracción que tenga
un numerador de 1 y bueno aquí ya puedo
ver a un octavo como una potencia de 2
también lo podríamos ver de la siguiente
manera esto es exactamente lo mismo un
octavo y voy a partir de aquí lo podemos
ver como un 8 elevado a la potencia
menos 1 lo único que estoy haciendo es
dándome cuenta que aquí el otro tiene en
la primera potencia está elevado a la
primera potencia y entonces como está
dividiendo yo lo puedo pasar con una
potencia negativa y esto es exactamente
lo mismo que 2 elevado al cubo esto lo
que representa a 8 elevado a la menos 1
fíjate que 2 elevado al cubo es 8 8
elevado al menos 1 lo cual es
exactamente lo mismo por 1 de las leyes
de los exponentes que me dice que una
base elevada a una potencia elevado a su
vez a otra potencia es exactamente lo
mismo que la base la base se conserva y
las potencias se multiplican aquí
tendría 3 x menos 1 lo cual es menos 3 y
llegamos justo a la misma respuesta
un octavo es 2 elevado al menos 3 y es
justo lo que querían perfecto entonces
en lugar de este un octavo am voy a
escribir lo cómodos elevado esto 2
elevado a la menos 3 o déjame ponerlo
con el mismo color esperan vamos a
escribirlo como 2 elevado a la menos 3
ok y aquí tengo un x y de igual manera
para un noveno si yo tengo un noveno y
déjame atraparlo con este color un
noveno lo podemos ver como 1 entre 3
elevado al cuadrado que es exactamente
lo mismo que 3 elevado a la menos y
recuerda que aquí estoy utilizando la
ley de los exponentes que me dice que
cuando tengo una base elevada a una
potencia positiva dividiendo la puedo
escribir como la misma base elevada a la
misma potencia solamente que negativa o
bueno también lo podemos ver como que un
noveno y un noveno es exactamente lo
mismo que 9 elevado a la menos 1 por la
misma propiedad y esto es exactamente lo
mismo que 3 elevado al cuadrado esto a
su vez elevado a la potencia menos 1 y
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 3
elevado a la menos 2 utilizando la
propiedad de las leyes de los exponentes
que me dice que cuando tengo una base
elevada una potencia el llamado otra
potencia es igual a la base elevado a la
multiplicación de las potencias perfecto
entonces en lugar de un noveno voy a
escribir 3 elevado a la menos 23 elevado
a la menos 2 de lujo entonces esto por 3
elevado a la menos 2 y todo esto todo
esto a su vez está elevado a la quinta
potencia todo esto está elevado a la
quinta potencia y bueno date aquí ya
está muy padre todo este asunto porque
ya tenemos toda esta expresión escrita
en base 2 y en base 3 ya todo esto tiene
que ver solamente con potencias de 2 y
con potencias de 3 que era justo lo que
queríamos entonces parece ser que esto
vaya bastante bien aquí tengo 3 elevado
a la potencia menos 2 ya esto lo voy a
multiplicar por y aquí tengo 2 elevado
al cuadrado elevado a su vez a la menos
2 y esa propiedad ya la hemos utilizado
la utilizamos justo aquí cuando tengo
una base elevada a un exponente esto a
su vez elevado a otro exponente los
exponentes pasan multiplicándose es
decir que esto es lo mismo que 2 elevado
a la 2 x menos 2 me queda menos 4 2
elevado a la menos 4 porque los
exponentes pasan multiplicándose y ahora
a esto lo voy a multiplicar por y aquí
date cuenta que puede ocupar otra vez la
misma propiedad que utilizamos justo
aquí si tenemos un producto de dos
números
a una potencia esto es exactamente lo
mismo que los números elevados en la
potencia esto es exactamente lo mismo
que el producto de los números elevados
a esa misma potencia es decir que a esto
lo podemos ver como 2 elevado a la menos
3 esto a su vez elevado a la quinta
potencia ya esto multiplicado por 3
elevado a la menos 23 elevado a la menos
2 esto a su vez elevado a la quinta
potencia esto a su vez elevado a la
quinta potencia vamos muy bien de lujo y
ahora voy a utilizar la ley de los
exponentes relacionados con esta
expresión que tengo aquí y esta
expresión que tengo aquí que por cierto
ya hemos utilizado varias veces así que
bueno esto me queda a 3 elevado a la
menos 23 elevado a la menos 2 que a su
vez multiplican que a su vez multiplica
a 2 elevado a la menos 4 que a su vez
multiplica y esto lo puedo ver como 2
elevado a la menos 3 por 5 lo cual es
menos 15 ocupando la regla
correspondiente
voy a multiplicar por 3 elevado a la
menos 2 por 5 lo cual es menos 10
recuerda que cuando tengo una base
elevada una potencia elevada a una
potencia es lo mismo que la base elevada
a la multiplicación de las potencias
menos 2 por 5 esto es exactamente igual
a menos 10 y de aquí ya puedes ver el
patrón seguramente estás viendo que ya
casi acabamos el problema porque si
ahora esto lo igualó a esta parte de
aquí déjame a copiarlo y voy a ver si lo
puedo pegar ok de lujo esto es
exactamente lo mismo o quiero hacerlo lo
mismo a esta igualdad que tengo aquí
entonces ya estamos muy cerca del final
porque aquí lo que voy a poder hacer es
relacionar las dos expresiones que
tienen la misma base vamos a utilizar un
color distinto me gusta el blanco voy a
utilizar esta expresión que tiene base 3
que tengo aquí y esta expresión que
tiene base 3 que tengo aquí y las voy a
reducir y me va a quedar que esto es lo
mismo que 3 elevado a la menos 2
as - 10 recuerda que hay una ley de los
exponentes que me dice que cuando tengo
una base elevada una potencia por la
misma base elevada otra potencia las
potencias se suman en este caso tengo
menos 2 más menos 10 lo cual es menos 2
menos 10 que es menos 12 menos 12 menos
dos más menos 10 esto es igual a menos
12 de lujo y por otra parte puedo
relacionar a las dos expresiones que
tienen la misma base dos que tengo justo
aquí si nosotros hacemos lo mismo esto
es 3 elevado al menos 12 por 2 elevado a
lahm y tengo una base elevado a una
potencia por la misma base elevado a
otra potencia las potencias se van a
sumar menos 4 más menos 15 menos 4
-15 esto es exactamente lo mismo que a
menos 19 menos 19 - 19 ok y esto esto
tiene que ser igual a esta expresión que
tenemos acá arriba justo a lo que
teníamos en un principio y aquí ya puedo
hacer una comparación de potencias ya
puedo igualar las potencias para que
esta igualdad se cumpla si tengo 3
elevado a la menos 12 por 2 elevado de
menos 19 y esto quiero que sea igual a 2
elevado a la anp por 3 elevado a la vez
entonces ya me puedo atrever a decir que
am am debe de valer menos 19 que es la
potencia del 2 ten cuidado -19 déjame
tomar el mismo color menos 19 y por otra
parte b b debe de valer a la potencia
del 3 que es menos 12 debe de valer
menos 12 para que se cumpla esta
igualdad y ahora si ya puede ocupar que
para que se cumpla esta igualdad las
potencias deben de ser iguales y
entonces obtengo justo esto que tengo
aquí y ya llegué al resultado a igual a
19 igual a menos 12 hacen que se cumpla
esta igualdad que tengo aquí y todo
gracias a que utilizamos el conocimiento
que hemos obtenido acerca de las leyes
de los exponentes